republican senator from arkansas tom
cotton
uh senator thank you very much uh for uh
being with me i appreciate it
uh as you could tell i'm i'm a little
charged up there seem to be
a lot of things that are pretty obvious
uh in
the midst of our world you clearly now
have a reputation for seeing things
early for being willing to stand up to
them
can you start by explaining when we hear
now the arguments about we saw the
hacks of the oil pipeline of the meat
supplier
the warnings about the power grid how is
congress
because we don't see it how is it that
they spend their time demonizing
americans
as the enemy when these things are
happening in real time and affecting our
lives today
well it's happening because democrats
realize that the conditions that they're
creating in the country and the results
of their policies are not going to help
them at the ballot box next year you
know
we just spent a week back in our home
states uh out of session
in the congress and i didn't hear once
comments about the past or about nancy
pelosi's obsession
with this commission or anything else i
heard lots of comments about how our
border is still wide open and kamala
harris hasn't even visited the border
or how everything from gas to food to
lumber is skyrocketing in price
whether we've got a crime wave across
our nation cities
that's what i heard about that's what
normal americans normal arkansans care
about
that's what decides elections but the
democrats know that their policies in no
small part are responsible
for higher crime and higher prices and
the border crisis
so they want to try to focus on the past
they want to focus on what matters to
them personally as opposed to what
matters to the voters and i think
they're going to pay a real price for
that
well it seems to be because there have
been some there's a recent election at
the
border around texas where the republican
one uh that they're seeing they seem to
be concerned about how minorities are
going to be voting
at least it's heartening i think you
would agree with me that with all of the
media
perpetuating the democrat line your
constituents
americans across the country still get
what's important
they're not being distracted by that do
you find that surprising considering its
legacy media
and big tech coming at them with the
same messages
i don't find it surprising though
because so many arkansans have learned
not to trust
everything they read in the new york
times what they see on cnn
i mean the lab leak theory of the origin
of the
coronavirus pandemic is a good example
of that i was pointing out at the
beginning of last year in the very first
days of this pandemic when most of
washington was obsessed with
the impeachment trial but you know this
virus didn't start up in some remote
mountain village next to a cave full of
bats it happened
in a city that's larger than new york
right down the street from the lab where
they researched these coronaviruses and
surely anyone with an ounce of common
sense would say well gosh maybe we
should take a look at that
and the media and the democrats because
they saw the coronavirus as a way
to attack president trump and hopefully
undermine his re-election
dismiss what i was saying is a fringe
conspiracy theory something that had
been debunked when obviously it had not
been
every bit of evidence we had pointed
towards that lab that's still the case
to this day now that donald trump is no
longer in the white house though they're
willing to
look at the facts as the facts and not
exactly admit they made a mistake
but acknowledge the reality of it and
when normal or kansans see
that kind of duplicity from the media
yeah then they understand that they
can't take everything the media reports
at face value
well see and then that's what's key it's
fascinating to me because you're dealing
with a pandemic
the potential as we've had millions dead
and that didn't even stop the democrats
from using that to maybe
compound the fear pointing at donald
trump
the the one person who's delivered the
element now that is freeing us
from uh this horrible experience the
vaccines
and he is the one that continued to be
berated
and vilified uh and it seems as though
you've got
a group of people and this i've always
wondered about someone like yourself
that you go to work with these people
you you deal with them
it's it's got to be remarkable we worry
about the kinds of people who are
willing to run for office
how with what you've experienced i know
you're committed to the country and that
that is thank goodness how is it that
you
put up with this uh when it comes to the
seriousness of the outcomes that we're
dealing with life and death here
well i love our country and i love
serving our country i did it in uniform
and i'm very happy to be uh
doing it once again in the united states
senate on behalf of the people of
arkansas so i understand that some
slings and arrows come with that
especially when you're willing to stand
up
and say unpopular truth at least truth
that are unpopular
with the media and with the democratic
party so they can use all the names and
all the slanders they want but that's
not going to stop me from doing what's
right from representing the common sense
views of our kansans
and trying to improve lives for
arkansans and for all americans
that's exactly what we need more of in
congress you know your position as a
single senator
for a state though has national and
international impact
when you do things for the right reasons
when i was on the left uh the work was
designed
to try to push good people away to get
people to not want to do certain things
and that i'm happy to say continues to
fail because of uh senators and
and uh patriots like you sir thank you
senator comp for joining me tonight i
appreciate it
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else